les quatre partis de la majorité ont
signé leur manifeste jean pierre soisson
est l'invité du journal échec du
satellite européen
les images de l'explosion de la plus
porteuse en direct dans le journal le
coup d'envoi de saint-etienne manchester
de violentes bagarres viennent d'éclater
dans les tribunes
mais messieurs bonsoir vous vous en
doutiez un peu le menu de la journée est
essentiellement politique
et même si parfois on a ici ou là le
sentiment d'une saturation dans le
public
force est bien de constater
qu'aujourd'hui les deux événements de la
journée marqueront une date que les
quatre grands partis de la majorité à
l'exception provisoire des radicaux se
soient mis d'accord pour signer un
manifeste commun à six mois des
élections cet important important mais
attendu et que les trois leaders des
partis de gauche se retrouvent aussi
autour d'une table pour savoir si oui ou
non le programme commun peut être
réactualisé c'est encore plus important
car là le résultat est beaucoup plus
incertain alors avant de tirer les
conséquences de cette première prise de
contact pour tout de suite de revoir le
film de cette journée un peu
particulière
à deux pas du palais bourbon le siège du
parti socialiste
georges marchais fait son entrée à 10
heures pile
accueillis par pierre bérégovoy et une
meute de journalistes
trois minutes plus tard françois
mitterrand à 10h07 robert femmes les 27
autres négociateurs sont déjà dans la
salle lorsque les trois leaders de la
gauche s'installe au milieu de leurs
délégations table en u les socialistes
sont entourés à leur gauche des
représentants communistes et à leur
droite des radicaux de gauche
la séance va commencer à 10h30 pour les
journalistes débute une longue journée
d'attenté les négociateurs vont déjeuner
sur place
avocat au crabe assortiment de viande
salade brésilienne tarte aux fraises
seul georges marchais va s'échapper
quelques instants pour prendre son café
au bar voisin de l'assemblée nationale a
commencé
chacun va faire il va d'après du monde
les chapitres le bilan et on va
reprendre les choses puisqu'il ya des
désaccords fait d'accord je veux dire ça
quand la discussion sera terminé
heureusement je peux pas en dire plus la
séance reprend à 15 heures reprend à 15h
et apparemment ne les copains pour
l'instant n'est toujours pas terminée
noël je crois que nous avons des preuves
de son manche oui allez-y non je pense
qu'un problème qui pour l'instant est
insoluble à essayer une dernière fois
non je crois que nous recommencerons un
petit peu plus tard dans ce journal
pendant tout techniciens s'affairent à
rectifier cette liaison est en liaison
très direct et on le comprendra avec ce
sommet de la gauche antenne 2 a choisi
de prolonger l'événement ce soir tout de
suite après le journal à 20h35 donc par
un débat tout à fait inédit je crois
qu'on a encore jamais vu ça à la
télévision entre georges séguy et edmond
maire
par on ne présente pas et jacques séry
de l'autre jacques séry c'est le vice
président du cnpf animation jean pierre
elkabbach et laurence graff un nous
présence tout de suite la portée d'un
tel débat sur le premier grand débat
l'élection de soixante dix huit réunies
tant directs prend des principaux
représentants de la vie économique et
sociale
jacques séry vice président du cnpf
georges séguy serait père général de la
cgt et edmond maire secrétaire général
de la cfdt
les participants aux débats viennent de
suivre avec beaucoup d'attention les
résultats du premier sommet sur le
programme commun en effet qu'ils soient
patrons et syndicalistes
l'enjeu des élections les touche
directement c'est ainsi qu'ils font
qu'ils vont discuter à la fois très
longue raffin proposition vous obliger à
nous verrons de kara l'instant mais nous
le voyons sur nos images
robert fabre sort de cette première
journée de négociations au siège du
parti socialiste souhaite que les trois
parties approfondissent leur réflexion
pour rechercher sent inutile polémique
et dans les meilleurs délais les bases
d'un accord
la déclaration je veux offrir au nom du
mouvement interdit pour cette
déclaration de robert fabre
immédiatement après il semble que
georges marchais souhaite aussi faire
une déclaration alors je dois vous dire
au nom de la délégation du parti
communiste français que nous avons été
extrêmement surpris par la déclaration
faite par la délégation des radicaux de
gauche qui avait demandé une suspension
de séance
en effet après que robert fabre françois
mitterrand et moi-même et lyon ce matin
ayant ce matin a fait la déclaration que
vous connaissez nous avons commencé
d'entreprendre page par page
l'examen du projet actualisé tels qu'ils
nous avaient été livrés par le groupe
des casses
nous étions arrivés à la fin du deuxième
chapitre
nous avions résolu en cours de route
pour pas mal de questions dont certaines
assez importante que je crois que sur
une quarantaine de deux questions nous
avions trouvé accord sur environ 30 il
est vrai que subsiste et un désaccord
sur le smic sur la hiérarchie des
salaires notamment
et nous en étions donc s'il vous plaît
les photographes parce que ils entendent
pas alors laisser opérer les
journalistes les photographes un peu
nous en étions donc arriver aux
nationalisations
évidemment nous n'avons formulé aucune
revendication nouvelles par rapport à
celles qui sont déjà connus et c'est à
ce moment là que le mouvement des
radicaux de gauche a décidé de rompre
unilatéralement la négociation engagée
j'ai proposé que nous poursuivions la
discussion dans l'esprit qui nous anime
est c'est à dire avec la volonté de
rechercher un accord les radicaux de
gauche y sont opposés j'ai proposé au
parti socialiste
dans le cas où les radicaux ne veulent
plus poursuivre la discussion avec nous
que nous poursuivions le débat ensemble
et enfin ultime proposition
la délégation du comité central du parti
communiste français sera demain matin
10h au siège du comité central près
puisque c'est là que la des discussions
devraient se poursuivre
nous sommes prêts à recevoir le parti
socialiste et les radicaux de gauche
s'il changer de position afin de
poursuivre la négociation pour aboutir à
un accord car telle est la volonté du
parti communiste français
je présume que les choses soient bien
claires nous sommes pour poursuivre le
débat et nous n'avons formulé aucune
revendication nouvelle qui justifie la
rupture unilatérale par les radicaux de
gauche
merci j'ai l'impression que nous venons
de vivre un moment assez important dans
l'histoire de cette négociation alors
noël copains nous avions assez mal
compris ce que disait tout à l'heure
robert femmes nous l'avons mieux compris
à travers les propos de georges marchais
il semble donc robert fabre au nom du
mouvement des radicaux de gauche et
décidé de quitter cette négociation
noël est bien cette liaison sont ne
s'est toujours pas rétabli c'est
vraiment dommage car je crois que nous
avons vécu une minute sinon historique
du mois très importante
robert fabre et le mouvement des
radicaux de gauche a donc décidé de
quitter cette négociation sur la
réactualisation du programme commun il
semble que georges marchais au nom des
communistes semblent vouloir poursuivre
la discussion avec les socialistes
il est vraiment regrettable que nous
n'ayons pas cette liaison avec le siège
du parti socialiste
car je crois que c'est une affaire très
importante qui sera appelé à être
développé dans les minutes qui viennent
vous avez vécu en direct ces propos de
robert fabre puis de georges marchais
j'imagine que je parmi les arguments des
uns et des autres tout à l'heure après
cette émission à 20h35 dans l'émission
de jean pierre elkabbach
on retrouvera bien sûr cette affaire de
la négociation du brand gonnin on
retrouvera aussi les nouveaux chiffres
du chômage communiqué aujourd'hui une
augmentation des demandeurs d'emploi
aussi bien en données brutes et en
données corrigées
une petite consolation les offres
d'emploi elles aussi ont augmenté d'un
peu plus de dix mille en attend
d'ailleurs au ministère du travail
une nouvelle reprise de ses offres en 70
pieds de nez de l'histoire ou de la
petite histoire comme on voudra pendant
que les trois partenaires de l'union de
la gauche figé leur sourire on l'a vu
pour commencé à éplucher les dossiers et
bien les quatre partenaires la majorité
tout le monde sauf les radicaux apposé
leur signature à quelques mètres de là
au bas d'un document qui tient
finalement en moins de douze pages
exactement huit pages et demi c'est le
manifeste de la majorité que nous
présente maintenant jean-louis de seine
jamais les dirigeants du centre national
des indépendants n'avait vu au siège de
leur parti autant de monde que ce matin
les quatre leaders de la majorité
présents et souriant par a fait en
public pour la première fois un texte de
huit pages
leur manifeste tout en regrettant
cependant l'absence de la cinquième
formation de la majorité le parti
radical de jean jacques servan shreiber
dans ce manifeste rien de bien nouveau
du moins rien qu'on ne sache déjà quatre
chapitres le premier concerne enjeux des
législatives de 78 on peut y lire nous
en appelons à votre lucidité
sous le titre notre bilan les
signataires estiment qu en commun que
nul ne peut contester que la vème
république a profondément améliorer les
conditions de vie des français prr p r
si eni et cds annoncent qu'ils
défendront au cours de la campagne
électorale les libertés la justice et
l'indépendance nationale pour l'avenir
il s'engage à lutter contre le chômage
à revoir le système fiscal et à
simplifier la législation sociale
en bref des idées d'ordre général que
chaque partie de la majorité maintenant
va s'efforcer de traduire et de
développer dans son propre programme
alors précisément avec nous l'un de ses
dirigeants
jean pierre soisson leur état général du
parti républicain la première question
qu'on a envie de vous poser jean pierre
c'est quand même la différence entre le
manifeste de la majorité une page et
puis le programme commun qui n'est pas
encore actualisé mais qui alors en 72
faisait 192 pas nombreux c'est parce que
les textes n'ont rien de commun si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi
alors alex pour rien non nous sommes
nous sommes nous d'accord sur
l'essentiel
alors c'est un accord qui manifeste
notre position commune sur les choix
fondamentaux de société que nous
présenterons ensemble aux français et
c'est pour cela que nous avons signé un
accord le 19 juillet et que ce manifeste
est prêt début septembre et par là même
nous tournons définitivement la page des
querelles au sein de la majorité il n'y
aura plus que rennes et nous
appliquerons les uns les autres
loyalement l'accord de juillet et nous
l'avons constaté par un communiqué que
nous avons rédigé ensemble dans l'après
midi
il ya un communiqué qu'il est facile à
eli lilly a picture elle il n'y a plus
de pure elle est désormais l'entente de
la majorité
c'est cette affirme est établi et c'est
d'affirmer pour nous parti républicain
sur quelques principes très simple
d'abord elle s'est affirmée au tour du
président de la république et c'est ce
que le préambule dit les français en
fait en 1974 un choix fondamental
le président l'année prochaine doit
pouvoir au parlement disposer d'une
majorité qui lui permettent de
poursuivre l'oeuvre d'adaptation de la
société française qu'il a acquise en
entreprise
et puis ensuite cet accord s'est fait
sur une base un peu offensif c'est à
dire que nous n'allons pas simplement
critiquer et ce qui se passe de l'autre
côté et on nous voyons que les choses
peuvent mal tourner nous voulons nous
aussi présenter aux français un projet
simple un projet clair qu'ils puissent
les rassembler et les mobiliser en
plaçant son canton vient de signer un
document n'est toujours tout sourit un
médecin un sourire qui cachent souvent
des discussions à six a dans ce document
n'a posé aucun problème
ce document devra être pour les uns et
les autres complétait et il sera
complété par les programmes des partis
et le parti républicain présentera le
mois prochain son projet là publiques
qui seront en opposition les uns et les
clients ayant pas de position et nous
sommes mis d'accord pour qu'il y ait une
base commune ça c'est la base commune à
partir du manifeste
nous allons les uns les autres affirmé
ce qui est notre particularité était
parce que nous avons affirmé aujourd'hui
l'entente de la majorité que nous
pourrons ensuite organiser la diversité
la majorité vous avez beau être 4 il y
en a toujours un ou deux qui sont en
position de leader et je pense que vous
suivez mon regard on pense toujours à la
chirac qui en tout cas tente lui de
tirer à lui cette unité la majorité il
n'y a pas de personnage ou de leaders
qui tirent la majorité à lui et il ne
saurait y avoir au sein de la majorité
un quelconque impérialistes signé pour
ma part et pour ma part je le dis très
clairement je le dis devant tous les
téléspectateurs pour ma part maintenant
je ne répondrai plus aux déclarations de
tel ou tel leader de la majorité qui
pourrait compromettre l'entendre de
cette majorité
je mets au préoccuperait bien plus de
répondre aux préoccupations des français
c'est pas très gentil pour 1700 chabert
si j'ai bien traduit
chacun traduit ce qu'il veut et moi je
pense ce que je croise de repenser le
sommet de la gauche lui la majorité deux
événements que raymond barre devait
commenté à la sortie du conseil des
ministres où soit dit par parenthèse on
avait abordé la protection du rhin
contre la pollution la revalorisation du
travail manuel
avec la création dès demain du livret
d'epargne manuel dont lionel stoléru
nous parlait à 18h40
et puis aussi le recrutement de vingt
mille vacataire dans la fonction
publique après ce conseil est donc le
premier ministre s'est essayé à une
comparaison entre les deux sommets de la
journée en parlant d'abord de la
majorité
kylie est une nation et qu'il n'y ait
une compétition des formations
politiques divers cela est très normal
et je crois que cela est très utile car
nous devons sortir d'une situation dans
laquelle la majorité était purement
monolithique
en revanche du côté de l'opposition les
divisions qui se font jour sont des
divisions très profond car elles portent
non seulement sur des mesures concrètes
mais je crois en fin de compte sur deux
conceptions différentes de la société
voilà qui est puis vraiment bar devait
se défendre ensuite d'entreprendre un
voyage électoraliste aux états unis il
par là bas ce soir je serai toujours
très soucieux de la dignité de mon pays
et de celle de la fonction de premier
ministre
devait-il dire donc après ce conseil
après que le prix du public
fait inhabituel et raccompagné son
premier sur le perron de l'elysée pour
lui souhaiter bon voyage en direct avec
nous maintenant noël copains la liaison
son est enfin rétabli est ce que vous
allez pouvoir nous expliquer ce qui
s'est exactement passé je crois qu'avec
vous vous avez robert fabre et oui
patrick je dois vous dire que nous avons
été ici au moins aussi surpris que vous
car d'après ce que nous savions de ces
négociations il paraissait que elle
s'était déroulée sur un ton assez vif
quelqu'un me disait ils se sont dits
tout ce qu'ils avaient à se dire mais on
pensait que la réunion a laissé l'homme
prolonger demain
j'ai donc à côté de moi monsieur robert
fabre et je lui pose tout de suite la
question que tout le monde attend
s'agit-il d'une rupture dans une
négociation
il est indispensable que des concessions
soient faites par les diverses parties
lorsque le débat s'est engagé ce matin
nous avons fait en ce qui nous concerne
sur un certain nombre de points mineurs
certes un certain nombre de concessions
vis-à-vis des propositions du parti
socialiste et des propositions du parti
communiste
lorsque nous sommes arrivés à ce que
nous considérons comme l'essentiel c'est
à dire l'économie parce que c'est
l'économie qui commande la possibilité
d'aménager les mesures sociales que
réclament les plus défavorisés nous
avons constaté de la part du parti
communiste d'une manière quasi
systématique un refus de prendre en
compte toutes nos propositions et aussi
un men qui est un des propositions qui
ont été énoncées par le parti communiste
et qui ne figure pas dans le programme
commun de 1972
en clair nous sommes arrivés à ce
constat c'est que les communistes
proposé que l'on poursuivre l'extension
des nationalisations
alors que nous avons mandat d'en rester
aux nombres de nationalisation qui
figure dans le programme commun et que
nous avons par ailleurs dit depuis
longtemps nous ne pouvions pas accepter
la nationalisation chaîne où la
nationalisation à la carte
ce sont des principes sur lesquels nous
ne pouvons pas transiger et un certain
nombre d'autres d'accord aussi important
que celui là ou presque nous ont amenés
à penser compte tenu aussi du climat de
la rencontre que le parti communiste ne
voulait pas véritablement aller vers un
accord en nous faisant le minimum de
concessions donc indispensable ou fait
porter sur le parti communiste et la
responsabilité de ce qui s'est produit
évidemment car nous n'avons pas dit
contrairement à ce que le parti
communiste et non ce que nous
faisions une rupture nous avons demandé
dans notre communiqué si la dernière
phrase que chaque partie se livre à une
réflexion et que dans l'intérêt même de
lyon de la gauche
ils reviennent à de meilleurs sentiments
de meilleures idées merci le parti
communiste prétend comme norme entendu
ce soir que sur ces points il ne peut
être que irréductibles nous ne voyons
pas pourquoi c'est nous qui fouillons
des concessions élections en même temps
nous avons demandé dans l'est plus dans
les meilleurs délais mais il n'y a
aucune raison pour que dans cette
affaire le mouvement des radicaux de
gauche qui correspond à un sentiment
très profond chez les français ce
sentiment c'est celui de la libre
entreprise du respect de l'initiative
individuelle et de la propriété soit
sacrifiée sur l'autel d'un programme
commun pierre ce moment là ne
corresponde pas du tout à nos voeux et
et qui ne seraient pas acceptées par la
marche a dit qu'il serait demain matin
10h au comité central du pcf et qu'il
vous attend dès que ferez vous mais nous
aurons demain nous en ce qui le concerne
un bureau national auquel nous rendrons
compte de la situation
robert fabre est ce que cela veut dire
que lui que le programme commun 72 vous
ne signerait le problème commun 77
oui la question que vous posez patrick
poivre d'arvor et que sans doute vous
n'avez pas entendu
est-ce que
vous ne signez pas plus le programme
commun de 1977 que vous n'avez signé en
son début le programme commun en 1972
c'est une question prématurée
il est évident que dans les conditions
actuelles
celle que je viens d'énoncer avec la
position que nous avons prises par
rapport à nos instances nationales le
mandat que nous avons nous ne pouvons
pas signer un programme qui comporte un
certain nombre d'applications et nous
avons dit que nous voulions rester
loyalement de lyon de la gauche mais pas
au prix d'un ralliement de nos principes
et quelle était l'attitude du parti
socialiste dans ce débat
vous demanderez à ses responsables de
vous exprimer et quel est votre
sentiment pensez vous qu'ils iront et
demain à cette réunion mais je n'ai
aucune idée là dessus je crois que les
socialistes sont totalement libres de
leur initiative et ils jugeront comme
ils penseront devoir le faire
en effet pendant cependant ils
constatent ils constatent comme nous le
même nombre de divergences que les
divergences importantes entre leurs
propres propositions et celles du parti
qu en dise oui nos copains je crois
qu'il faut que vous nous rappeler lié
d'ici à la fin de ce journal pour nous
dire exactement quelle est la position
du parti socialiste dans cette affaire
qui me paraît donc très important et
maintenant notre grande enquête de la
semaine sur la santé des économies
occidentales dans un instant nous nous
pencherons sur la nôtre avec
l'économiste jean-jacques rosa mais tout
de suite un regard sur l'une de celles
que l'on dit les plus florissantes
l'économie allemande cet été au cours de
leurs vacances étrangères les allemands
n'ont pu s'empêcher de constater que le
deutschmark était une monnaie forte
en moyenne leur pouvoir d'achat estivale
était une fois et demi supérieur à celui
d'un vacancier français la monnaie
allemande est l'une des plus fortes du
monde
cela n'exclut cependant pas des
difficultés une peur de l'avenir
économique et un taux du chômage élevé
un million de chômeurs en allemagne
ça c'est considéré comme grave parce que
le million c'est une limite aux logiques
technologique
mais qui sont ces chômeurs et bien ce
sont des femmes spécialement il ya des
jeunes parmi ce sont les deux groupes
qui sont graves et puis il ya un groupe
qui ne devrait pas être chômeurs qui
refusent d'accepter un emploi un peu
moins bien payé que celui qui l'en perdu
aucune recette habituelle de lutte
contre la récession n'a pour l'instant
réussi à résorber le chômage des jeunes
de plus environ 20 % des chômeurs
trouverait du travail s'il acceptait de
gagner un peu moins
c'est dire si outre-rhin le chômage est
devenu une plaie difficilement curables
est d'autant plus insupportable qu'elle
persiste dans un milieu de relative
opulence le secteur le plus touché par
la récession plutôt la stagnation prête
le bâtiment les autres secteurs
industriels ne sont cependant pas
épargné
il faudrait à l'allemagne en 77 une
croissance d'environ 5% pour assurer le
plein emploi
on craint que cette croissance
n'atteigne que trois et demi pour cent
environ l'allemagne fédérale subit en
effet le contrecoup des baisses
d'activité économique des pays voisins
c'est normal et même fatale pour un pays
où un travailleur sur quatre travaillent
pour l'exportation
les industriels allemands espèrent que
dans les prochains mois les perspectives
de ventes et s'amélioreront en allemagne
à l'étranger un plan de relance est en
effet sur le point d'être décidée à bonn
en harmonie avec la france notamment
on attend cependant pas des miracles
d'un train de mesures dont l'objectif
est d'encourager les ménages allemands à
consommer plus et les chefs d'entreprise
à mieux investir des trois mesures
encore but premièrement de mettre les
consommateurs en état de consommer plus
quand une paie moins d'impôts il leur
est plus grand pour consommer et de
laisser aux entrepreneurs
plus d'argent plus d'argent pour
investir littéralement accordera donc
une remise fiscale de l'ordre de 10
milliards de deutschemarks il acceptera
en outre un budget national en déficit
pour 78 la relance passe donc ici par la
redécouverte d'habitude dispendieuse
après bernard piganiol lundi lens à
bussy hier avec nous donc ce soir
l'économiste libéral jean jacques rosa
venez participer dans douze jours à la
convention économie et libertés qui doit
définir je cite un programme pas commun
cela dit bien ce que ça veut dire vous
n'êtes pas dans le camp de la gauche
alors ma première question a trait aux
reportages que nous venons de voir les
allemands ont bien subi comme le
prélèvement pétroliers et pourtant ils
ont l'air d'avoir mieux que nous
surmonter cette crise alors qu en effet
que c'est important la situation de
l'allemagne montre que tout n'est pas
question de crise pétrolière la
performance actuelle des économies
industrielles mais il ya des raisons
plus profondes à la crise et certains
pays ont mieux traversé la crise que
d'autres engins qu'on va vous êtes un
économiste libéral donc vous êtes pour
le libéralisme c'est quand même ce
libéralisme qui permet nous n'avons
entendu tout à l'heure près d'un million
deux cent mille sûrement oui j'adore le
problème du chômage est souvent mal
compris je crois on al'impression
souvent que les chômeurs sont des
chômeurs permanent or il faut bien avoir
quelques chiffres en tête si par exemple
16 % de la population active changent
d'emploi dans une année et attend en
moyenne trois mois pour retrouver un
emploi eh bien ça va nous donner un
chiffre de 4 % de chômage
et si maintenant obligés d'attendre
trois mois en moyenne chacun des
chômeurs à temps six mois cela va
augmenter le taux chômage à 8%
c'est dire que la durée moyenne du
chômage est le facteur décisif pour
expliquer le taux de chômage à l'arrêt
et vos adversaires vont dire c'est une
philosophie d'extrême droite libéralisme
du loup dans la bergerie
écoutez le libéralisme c'est le
contraire de l'extrême droite puisque en
général les politiques d'extrême droite
ont recours aux corporatismes à
l'intervention massive de l'état il ya
des exemples historiques récents qu'ils
montrent bien l'allemagne nazie
les fascistes le libéralisme au
contraire s'appuie sur l'individu et
veut laisser l'individu s'exprimer
complètement
alors pourquoi est ce qu un libéral
comme vous peut elle mettre
l'intervention des tables d'affaires de
la sidérurgie en l'a vu récemment va le
revoir tout à l'air dans le débat avec
jacques riz en tant que libéral je
serais plutôt opposés aux subventions
qui sont donnés à l'industrie
sidérurgique
en effet il n'est pas normal que ce
soient les contribuables qui paient et
les sidérurgistes et qui supprime ainsi
tout risque dans cette activité alors
que la seule justification du profit
c'est de supporter le risque est ce que
à votre avis quelles peuvent être les
conséquences pour l'économie française
d'une vingtaine victoire de la gauche en
mars
eh bien les conséquences je pense
peuvent être assez grave pour la
croissance
parce que les économistes de gauche
continuent à croire aux recettes
keynésiennes qui était valable il ya 40
ou 50 ans mais qui ne sont plus
aujourd'hui et en voulant relancer
massivement la consommation ils vont
aboutir à relancer l'inflation
sans donner de solution au problème de
l'emploi ainsi un condamné il faut
maintenant que nous évoquions cet échec
assez retentissant cette nuit du
satellite européen au ts la fusée
porteuse qui elle était américaine à une
défaillance elle a explosé au bout de
quelques secondes de vol et tout cela
ruine plusieurs années de travail de
nombreux techniciens européens parmi
lesquels 150 spécialistes de chez matra
petite consolation le satellite était
assurée pour 150 millions de francs en
allons pouvoir leur construire et le
lancer à nouveau dans six mois 1h31 du
matin décollage parfait de la fusée
delta depuis le pas de tir numéro 17 de
cap canaveral à bord un satellite
européen ets porteur d espoir
d'indépendance d'un vieux continent
en matière de télécommunications la
fusée elle est américaine construit par
mcdonnell douglas lancé par la nasa
la fusée delta a toujours bien
fonctionné depuis plus de dix ans sauf
une fois en avril dernier pour un
satellite européen
geos alors pour mieux nous permettre de
voir georges le père vous avez apporté à
une maquette de cette fusée qu'est ce
qui n'a pas été envoyée ici il ya neuf
petites fusées 5 s'allume dès le
décollage est au bout de dix kilomètres
d'altitude une minute environ
elle se retire elle cesse leurs
fonctions et les quatre autres s'allume
c'est à ce moment là que tout a explosé
je vous propose de voir directement sur
cette fusée qui est encore en train de
décoller comment ça s'est passé
c'est une affaire de seconde regardez
bien cette fusée elle va exploser dans
quelques secondes
voilà et avec ce mauvais fonctionnement
du petit élément de fusées au tfc perdu
des millions s'envolent en fumée
on parle de sabotage de négligence de
malchance mais la réalité différente ces
fusées n'ont plus que deux à trois ans
de service car après viendra l'ère de la
navette spatiale qui remplacera toutes
les fusées américaines y compris celles
ci c'est du moins l'avis des
responsables européens de tsn
les deux partenaires qui sont en jeu
dans cette affaire c'est la nasa essaie
maintenant de la glisse qui fabrique le
nonce et pour eux c'est une catastrophe
à la fois vous avez une mauvaise
publicité mauvaise publicité vous avez
la réputation de la nasa qui est un
religieux
vous avez la réputation de m dos d'un
gloss qui est aussi en jeu juste au
moment là que le il veut vendre
davantage de telles que finalement la
philosophie de cet échec patrick c'est
que les européens doivent absolument
disposer de leur propre fusée voici
ariane la fusée européenne
elle sera tirée pour la première fois en
1979 elle sera près de deux ans après
fin 80 1981 elle aurait pu lancer au ts
en fait on aurait pu même m 2 au ts dans
cette fois ne peut pas attendre 80 parce
que le monde des télécommunications va
évolue à toute vitesse la télévision
directe derrière soi c'est un exemple
alors si on attend que la fusée ariane
soient prêtes on sera en retard c'est
pour ça que ts le numéro 2 fera quand
même lancé par utl torts delta la même
fusée qui exposait cette nuit mais dans
six à huit mois c'est georges leclercq
ce journal décidément bouleversé par
l'actualité une actualité assez
passionnante ce soir il faut bien le
reconnaître
le copain un petit point très rapide
pour savoir la position des socialistes
il est impossible il est impossible
d'indiquer la paix par léon vouvry il
est impossible d'indiquer la position
des socialistes
aucun dirigeant du parti socialiste n'a
voulu faire de déclaration tout à
l'heure lorsqu'il y a eu ce coup de
théâtre la délégation du parti
socialiste est actuellement réunis à
huis clos bien sûr pour savoir quelle
position adopter mais je voudrais fait
aucune déclaration n'a été faite
alors si vous voulez on peut quand même
essayer d'imaginer ce que peut être
l'attitude du parti socialiste
j'ai quand même non je crois qu'il est
préférable que vous nous rappeler liées
au besoin dans l'émission de jean pierre
elkabbach tout de suite après ce journal
pour nous dire exactement le point la
situation une situation tendue mouvante
donc et maintenant comme promis il
heures de notre rendez vous avec le
football dans quelques secondes
le coup d'envoi à saint-etienne du match
que les verts vont livrer contre
manchester
je rappelle qu à 22h45 vous pourrez
assister sur antenne 2 à la
retransmission intégrale en différé bien
sûr du match que nantes dispute ce soir
aussi à prague
à ce moment vous aurez aussi les
résultats des deux autres rencontres
lens contre malmö et bastia contre
lisbonne pour l'heure donc les premières
minutes les premières secondes de
saint-etienne manchester avec sur place
pierre salviac un mot peut-être des
incidents qui ont émaillé le début de
cette partie ont en tout cas l'avs en
partie oui pour voir ici le stade
geoffroy guichard pour ce match de coupe
d'europe des vainqueurs de coupe entre
saint-etienne et manchester en maillot
rouge sur votre écran oui ce match de
coupe a commencé dans le drame 2000
supporteurs de manchester excité vivre
meurent même en provoquer de graves
incidents dans la tribune populaire sud
ils ont commencé par envoyer des
bouteilles pleines sur les supporteurs
verts de violentes bagarres ont alors
éclaté provoquant un mouvement de foule
le résultat tout cela est bien l église
de protection s'était enfoncée la foule
a envahi la pelouse provoquant l'arrêt
prématuré du match des rideaux cela ne
s'était jamais vu
à saint-etienne imaginez donc l'ambiance
ce soir les locaux du club ont été
transformés aussitôt en affirmant dits
de première urgence
le bilan est lourd on dénombre de
nombreuses fractures ouvertes tandis que
des femmes un sol et ont été transportés
en du stade est victime d'une crise de
nerfs le service d'ordre matraque au
poing envahi la tribune enragé pour
établir une frontière entre les
supporteurs français anglais je vous
assure que c'est nécessaire ce soir pour
l'instant le calme semble revenu mais
l'ambiance et vous l'entendez et
surchauffée pour la petite histoire je
voulais vous dire aussi que les
dirigeants de saint-etienne on lit ce
matin dans les bus et filets anti
projectiles c'est une nouveauté à
geoffroy guichard
détail piquant instruisez qui sont
invisibles ont été fabriqués en
angleterre voilà donc les terribles le
supporteur de manchester prévenu ici
donc à geoffroy guichard
le match est commencé depuis une minute
entre saint-etienne et volent chercheurs
toujours 0 à 0 mais une ambiance
terrible surchauffée a du talent
merci beaucoup pierre salviac les
résultats donc à 22h35 pour une émission
spéciale du service des sports à 22h45
je vous rappelle en différé le match
nantes prague
j'espère que vous aurez un petit peu
pardonner l'aspect désordonnée de ce
journal mais je crois que nous avons
vécu en direct
deux événements très importants je
rappelle que pour l'instant le mouvement
des radicaux de gauche a provisoirement
quitté la négociation sur la réalisation
du programme commun le temps pour
terminer si bien il sera encore
ensoleillé demain sur la france
cependant il faut prévoir quelques
petits nuages sur le nord et le nord-est
prévoir aussi des températures plus
basses
vous avez donc de rendez vous avec
l'information dans quelques secondes
le débat ferry seguy mer et puis tout à
fait en fin de programme vers 00h15
après le match détiennent le dernier
journal berner claude à tous une très
très bonne soirée en compagnie de notre
équipe à demain